si vous cherchez un téléviseur pour
regarder notamment le grand événement
vous aurez à la fin de l'année sur le
football et bien venez jeter un coup
d'œil chez TCL ils ont énormément de
produits derrière moi il y a une 98
pouces série c'est 735 énorme télé il y
a plein de tailles plein de références
65 55 pouces et vous montrez celle-là
déjà vous allez voir elle est super
canon 4K IMAX division IQ Dolby Atmos
Todd rafraîchissement de 120 Hertz vous
avez bref une fiche technique qui est
énorme alors là c'est un très grand
modèle de 98 pouces mais vous pouvez la
voir un peu plus petit si vous le
souhaitez à vous de voir d'ailleurs si
vous aimez football TCL à 4 ambassadeurs
de renom Rodrigo feelfhoden Raphaël
Varane et pedri donc si vous cherchez un
téléviseur pour regarder notamment le
grand événement de football qui aura
lieu à la fin de l'année pensez à TCL
TCL allez jeter un coup d’œil sur leur
site vous allez voir il y a plein de
références plein de produits et
notamment des télés toutes les tailles
c'est super intéressant allez-y go on
fonce